-I feel terrible,
because we talk a fair amoun
about soccer.
You're a Liverpool fan.
And I know you've
talked about this
and how heartbreaking it is.
You were basically on your way
to your first
Premier League title,
and I feel like a jinx because
I waited and waited and waited
until it seemed like
it was the safest...
-Yeah.
-...the safe, was so locked up
and I feel like
I blew it for you.
-It's not just that --
it's not just that
they were so close
to winning it.
Well, it is that.
But it's also they were
winning it so beautifully.
-So convincingly, and it fel
like nothing could stop them
Now you think,
short of a global pandemic
but a global pandemic, you know,
is a hell of an opponent,
and it turns out it really
shuts some [bleep] down.
-Yeah.
-Yep.
-It is not -- it is not
the thing I am saddest about..
-No, nor should it be.
-...but I want you to know
I saved a little piece
of sadness for it.
-I appreciate that.
It's just
they deserve it so much.
And obviously, obviously,
when you inject just the modicum
of perspective, it doesn't
matter, it will never matter
But, you know, as a sports fan
perspective doesn't
come naturally, does it?
-No.
-You have to kind of --
You have to really convinc
yourself, "This doesn't matter
This is just adults
playing a game.
It's okay.
It doesn't matter.
I should not be
more upset about this
than I am about
other things in my life."
However -- I remember --
I remember --
Do you remember
that World Cup game?
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-I remember
your instinctive reaction
after realizing that Holland
had just been knocked out,
was to say, "I love my wife.
My brother's my best friend.
-[ Laughs ]
-Not like you felt it.
More like, "I need to walk
myself back through this."
And, boy, boy,
did I identify with that.
"I gotta go through
the checklist here
to get myself back
into being a rational,
functioning human being."
-But that is the joy of it
I think the only reason
to like sports
is to give yourself a thing...
-Yes.
-...where you check rational
at the door.
-Of course. That's the beaut
of escapism, right?
-You think you can't possibly --
I can't, I still --
I'm a relatively
balanced human being.
Even coming out,
that sounds wrong.
But I can
kind of talk to anybody,
but I cannot talk to athletes.
I can't.
I just have nothing in common.
They still have a god-like -
I went to see Liverpool
just when they did
a preseason game
just before this season.
And I just --
I couldn't handle it.
I couldn't handle it at all.
I went down
to the dressing room,
and they were all coming out
Klopp came out,
and I couldn't --
You know, I couldn't
say anything to him.
Jordan -- I tried to talk
to Jordan Henderson for a bit,
didn't really work.
And then -- but this is true
I can't remember
if I told you this.
Virgil van Dijk walked out
and he looked at me,
and he said, "Zazu."
I went, "What?"
[ Both laugh ]
"What are you talking about?
He went, "Oh, Zazu --
I love 'The Lion King.'"
And I said,
"You don't have any children,"
which is not information that,
as a stranger,
I should be, like,
throwing in his face.
He went, "No,
I just like 'The Lion King.'
I recognized you as Zazu."
So, you know,
I guess that was good.
It was a connection of sorts
It gave us something
to talk about.
-So, you're saying that
not a single person
on the Liverpool squad
complimented you
for your deep dives on,
say, voting rights?
Not one?
Just Zazu?
-I mean, honestly,
when Adam Lallana walked out
I thought he was about to sa
something about gerrymandering
but I don't know.
He just...
[ Both laugh ]
I think he wanted
to talk about watches instead.
-[ Laughs ]